none of us here today can claim that we
have experienced or achieved overall
uncontestable success in terms of making
citizens understand what we do who we
are or what we are trying to achieve
here open data is an ingredient for
economic growth as well with many
entrepreneurs taking our datasets and
doing things with them adding value
present him in different ways as well I
think given the current economic
circumstances that's a particularly
important driver of the gender know that
this stuff allows us allows people to
create economic growth as well so it's
actually critical as not just a nice to
have ilysm must have publishing crime
statistics on a street by street level
and that went major in 10 months with 47
million visits to that website we
publish every single salary on a monthly
basis I'm not this is not to advertise
I'm just saying that there are many
different definitions of open government
and then there's always this question
inside and outside government what is
better is more the best or is you know
does it have to be a common sense there
the government olivia is very open
comparing to all kinds of international
standards we have very wide access to
documents and information and officials
are open to comments the decision-making
procedures are open to public all
documents are published on a timely
basis available for reading and comments
and your suggestions and if you have
submitted a reasonable proposal you will
be invited to be part of the official
working group and then it goes on until
the Parliament you can go to the
Parliament and it can happen to anybody
if you really want to be engaged I was
very frustrated I thought all these
opened and an open government would be
would be normal I would I should be able
to access all these statistics and I
should be able to just play with data
and so and that's why we started them an
open knowledge foundation open
government is more than open data alone
but if you don't have open data we don't
have an open government I have a simple
question who cares we need to make
things very visually appealing with the
infographic
or just things that cause people to
glance at and engage as a fine art when
we have to use video more often but it
does come back down to the storytelling
art how did we see why this is relevant
to you and why we would love you to take
part and that's that's a big
communications challenge if we create
the right conditions and allow the data
to be there it would be picked up I mean
there is maybe a generation out there
who are looking at this data what states
are we now I mean is it like ten percent
we can reach or are we already on eighty
or ninety percent and browsing we have
no open data there's no opening license
that are available at this moment so we
really need at this moment a lot of work
into into helping these small
governments and to open eye opening up
their their data I think we've forgotten
the guy in the street this man is he has
probably have a problem with water
heights is having a real problem here or
this is my mother-in-law and she's
learning how to work with an iPad
because she wanted to move to another
house and it was very difficult for her
to get the right information on where
she could live in basic I think we've
forgotten to look at a societal at
society perspective digital technologies
change the overall setting and it is
clear that while the opportunities in
terms of access and reuse of of
information thanks to digital
technologies are multiplied also the
legislation on personally the protection
and on intellectual property rights
needs to be updated to take into account
the new digital paradigm EU institutions
the Parliament and also the loans are
looking at a commission proposal to
update the data professionals and to
make sure that they are applied
consistently across the EU but the
future of open data is not within
discussing about licenses or discussing
about if it's personal data or not it's
about how we could engage the society
and how we can can work with open dot
which really solves issues with a
society
you